, we have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David P..
I've heard from so many people about these bogus
claims that windmills, wind farms don't work in
cold weather. Here is one such voicemail
I received making some very good points.
Hi, baby. My name is Prince, I live in California.
Yes, you were talking about Ted Cruz in his mind
and I'm sorry, and lying about the power grid, you
neglected to mention that the twin windmills are
working in Alaska. Yes, it's very cold all the
time. And solar power works in space like Mars.
And in the space shuttle, we're minus
three hundred degrees. So the cold does
not affect me the same way, correct? I do, yeah.
I mean, listen, you don't need to go to Mars
or NAS, as Donald Trump is to call it. You
don't need to go to outer space or Alaska.
Wyoming and Montana have properly winterized wind
turbines. They work fine. It's it is a ruse that
it is merely because of green energy. As we know,
the vast majority of the failures in Texas during
the storms were natural gas, coal and nuclear
caused by lack of winterization. This happened
in 2011. A report was compiled which said, here's
how you winterize all of these types of energy
power generation mechanisms. It wasn't done. The
same thing happened in 2021. It's that simple. We
have a great bonus show for you today. We have
news about the third coronavirus vaccine and we
will discuss that. Lawmakers are now targeting
the video game, Grand Theft Auto, because of an
increase in real world carjackings. What we're
doing this again. Plus, how can they come after
Grand Theft Auto? It's like the only video game
that I liked playing growing up as a kid. OK,
and then Tiger Woods was in a single car accident.
I'm not so much going to talk about the accident.
I'm going to talk about whether that's really
news and what it means about the news cycle that
it was so widely covered. You can probably guess
some of the questions we'll be asking. And there
are probably more discussions to be had there as
well. All of those stories on today's bonus show
get instant access to the bonus show. You know
how to do it. You go to join Pakman dot com.
You sign up, you hit the you hit the big
red sign up button and within seconds
you will be listening to or watching
today's bonus show. I'll see you then.